What is this vital information that needs to go in the bug report?
In a 2008 study involving 165 developers from Apache, Eclipse, and Mozilla,
the most important facts the developers needed were facts about the problem.
First, the problem history.
That is, steps needed to reproduce the problem.
For instance, start preview and then open the attached file.
Second, diagnostic information.
That is, core dumps, meaning memory dumps of the final stage of the program before it crashed,
stack traces, the functions that were active at the moment the failure occurred, or logs.
Whatever the system has recorded about the final state,
and what the program has logged so far.
Next, the experienced behavior.
This is what the user saw.
For instance, preview crashed.
Next, the expected behavior.
This is helpful as a reality check.
Does the user expect the same as the developer?
Mostly, this is just the opposite of the experienced behavior.
Finally, a one-line summary.
This is typically the base for searching for a bug report,
as well as for deciding the severity of a problem.
For instance, preview crashes when opening PDF file.